[Music]
hello everyone
so in the previous part of the
discussion we had arrived
at this specific form of the relation
between the stresses and the strains
through this elasticity tensor this
fourth order order elasticity tensor
and at the end of that discussion i had
mentioned
that we would be discussing certain ways
of simplifying this
relationship so uh first of all we note
that this fourth order elasticity tensor
c i j k l uh
how many independent constants does it
have
okay so indepen i seek independent
constants
because please note that we are working
under the assumption
of uniformity or homogeneity so uh
so different parts of the material of
the body
would have the same value okay so in
that sense it's a constant
so now we have these uh these four
indices in this in the subscript so this
indicates
that because each of these indices
go over three numbers one two three so
in total
we'll have three into three
into three into three so in total 81
okay 81 different elements or 81
different components
of this fourth order tensor and that is
true for any fourth order tensor
okay so the first thing would be to try
to simplify
uh to a situation where these 81
different apparently different
components uh
can be reduced in number
based on certain physical considerations
okay based on what you have studied
in the previous chapters so towards the
end uh
we'll go to the next page and start our
discussion of
a new topic called minor symmetries
all right so uh
we'll again consider this relation sigma
i j is equal to
i j kl epsilon
here now
what we'll do is we'll simply
interchange
the ing no harm done okay
we interchange
we'll see what is the motivation behind
that we interchange
i and j okay so instead of
doing this we might as well have done
that we set i equal to p
and always change i to p and j to
q similarly on the right hand side you
would have changed i to
p and j to q no harm done in a similar
fashion
we just interchange i and j whatever the
information is captured in this relation
that remains undisturbed so what we have
here
is sigma j i is equal to
c j i a l
and this remains unchanged now
if we subtract this relation from this
relation what do you think will happen
you please uh so let's do that actually
so
suppose uh suppose we name
this one as hash one
this number is one and this one is
numbered as hash two
what we want to do is hash one
minus hash two okay
so that will give us sigma ij
minus sigma ji is
equal to the ij
l minus c
j i k l
bracket epsilon k but
we already know from the symmetricity of
the stress tensor
that sigma ij is equal to
sigma ji therefore
okay so what we have is
0 is equal to the i j k l
minus c j i k l
epsilon k now in general
none of the components of this
resistance a strain tensor epsilon k
is going to be zero so in general that's
that's what is going to happen in
general
none of the strain components we expect
to be zero so the only possibility for
this relation
to be true is that c i j k l
must be equal to c j i k l
okay so basically it does not make any
difference
if we interchange the the first two
indices
of the elasticity tensor okay so this is
only one of the first
or one of the minor symmetries uh next
what we are going to do
is interchange kml
so again we have sigma
i j so that remains undisturbed this
time but on the right hand side
we have the ij lk
and epsilon lk
we number this as hash three
and when we do a hash one minus
hash three
on the left hand side we have
zero and on the right hand side we have
c
i j k l minus
c i j l k
uh sorry i should not be writing like
this right away
make this correction so this is
epsilon kl minus
c i j l k
epsilon l k but
we know that epsilon k l is equal to
epsilon
l k okay from the symmetricity of the
strain density
so what we'll have is
0 is equal to the ij
kl minus cij
lk multiplied either by epsilon
l or epsilon l k doesn't make any
difference and again
the argument is that since the
the the components of the strain tensor
are
not going to be zero in general
therefore
we can conclude that c i j
k l is going to be equal to c i j
and k so these two things that we have
just obtained
uh let me go to the next page
and number this page
so just now what we have obtained that
the ij
is equal to i j
l k these two pieces of information
they are together referred to as the
minor
symmetries of the elasticity tensor
okay minor symmetries of the elasticity
tensor cig
here okay now uh
what uh the benefit of these minor
symmetries
is that uh the
the relations uh the sigma
i j uh
equal to c i j k l uh
epsilon kl that relation
which is apparently captured by these
what was originally these if we go back
is 81 constants we can actually realize
that this has been significantly uh
reduced so this
this apparently 81 independent
components this number has been
actually reduced so let's see how it has
happened so here
when we are talking about this c the the
interchangeability of the i j
the first two uh indices so
as a result of this what we can conclude
from here
is that instead of the uh
the 3 into 3 into 3 into 3 what we
really have
is 3 into 2 into 3
into 3. the 3 into 2 is happening
because the the i j
uh the interchangeability of i j tells
us that
uh this is basically a combination and
not a permutation
okay so suppose you had i equal to 1
here
and j equal to 2 here so it is exactly
the same thing
as 2 here and 1 here okay
so if it had been true that 1
2 is not the same thing as 2 1 here then
that would have been a permutation
but here we have one two sitting here
one to kl let's say is
is the same thing as c 2 1 k l whatever
the k and
l may be so it's basically that that
interchangeably tells us that this is a
combination so we have this kind of a
thing here all right furthermore if we
go to the
next one here so this is basically
telling us
that already we are having this
three into two now again the
interchangeability between k and
l is telling us that those two positions
are uh or the end indices sitting on
those two
positions are no longer like a
permutation instead they are like
combination
so what we have here is 3 into 2 again
so if we just just take stock off here
at this place what we had was 3 2
6 into 3 9 so it's 54 constants here
so from 81 constants we have reduced it
to 54 constants at this stage
and here we have further reduced it to 3
into 2
6 into 2 6 equal to 36 constants
okay we don't need to write this
for a six constants okay so from 81
it has been considerably reduced to 36
constants
all right so this is the major benefit
of the minor symmetries
uh now uh
what this minor symmetry also gives us
as an
added benefit uh that we have uh
actually obtained these
36 different values is that
the way that we can represent
on a piece of paper or on the screen how
the relationship between the sigma
tensor
and the epsilon tensor can be written
that can be considerably signified
and that will see in the next part of
the lecture so through something
called the uh void notation uh
which will actually also help us to
answer one question which some of you
have been asking me
since the chapter on mathematical
preliminaries okay
so we'll see how that goes about all
right thank you